foreign
[Music]
welcome everybody
um I hope you all are having a good
Cloud next and uh it looks like it's a
brilliant day outside but I'm know we're
all excited to hear about Cloud
infrastructure for your data intensive
workloads so thank you for coming and
we've got some interesting uh
information we want to convey to you
today
we have some great speakers I'm going to
lead off and then we're going to have
Sandeep Kohli from senior vice president
of engineering from Flipkart tell you
about their Journey from on-prem to
Google cloud and then we're going to
have Jason Pohl senior director of data
management for databricks and he's going
to tell you about how Google and
databricks are working together to build
a collaborative solution to help you run
your data intensive workloads
all right and then we'll have a q a and
uh Marco and vivac who are both product
managers for Google Cloud Storage are
going to come up on stage and help with
q a and I don't think I mentioned it I'm
a product manager in Google Cloud
Storage as well so
all right
a common message that you're going to
hear at a number of our sessions is how
Google is working very hard to enable
you to run your AI ml workloads your
Cloud native workloads and your inner
classic Enterprise storage workloads
we're helping to make them performant
secure and reliable and so this is just
look for this messaging throughout
you'll hear it several times in other
sessions
let's dive into Data building data
ecosystems and let's start out make sure
we're all level set so when I say data
intensive workloads what I'm talking
about is just answering questions could
be real simple questions like how many
customers do I have it could be
something more involved like which
customers are placing which orders on
Wednesdays that sort of thing and the
reason we want to do it is we want to
you know make our businesses grow and
and meet our business objectives and we
do this by running workloads that we all
commonly refer to as AIML which is super
popular these days
analytics more traditional reference and
high performance Computing so when I say
data intensive workloads we're talking
about all these things that we typically
identify with
so what do we need to run these
workloads together effectively if you
just start say go and you spin up your
VMS and you attach your storage to it
what invariably happens is you end up
with a bunch of data silos there's a lot
of problems with data silos they are
they have a problem with availability
they're
um there's a lot of copies of your data
ends up all over the place things get
out of sync you have high egress costs
and it's time consuming keep them
running so really the solution is uh to
get all your data in one place and with
Google Cloud Storage we give you a
single source of Truth to place your
data it also gives you a global endpoint
and Geo redundancy automatically and it
also places your data where you need it
all right so
um we find that people are like that's
great but we've invested heavily in
these in in a bunch of tools and we want
to make sure that we can still use those
tools we're 100 behind you and we do
everything we can to support you whether
you're running uh first party Google
products such as bigquery or open uh
Source Products like hdfs or spark or
partner products like databricks and
we'll be talking more you'll hear more
from databricks in a few minutes here so
we're here to support you you choose the
tool and we'll support you in Google
Cloud Storage
all right now if you're using uh Google
services we've built an entire ecosystem
to help you run your data intensive
workloads we put your data at the center
of this ecosystem so when you want to
ingest your data you can use things like
storage transfer service or the data
Appliance and then once the data is in
in the cloud we provide services like
dataproc and bigquery to do data
processing now as your data grows and
you get more and more of it it gets
difficult to manage you don't know where
it is you have security issues we
provide additional services like
dataplex to help you manage these
difficult data management issues
and of course we provide world-class
security and user experience and iam
all right so specifically in cloud
storage uh how we help you run your data
intensive workloads is
um we focus on making available in the
way that you need it so let me talk a
little bit about our location types we
have three location types uh Regional
dual region and multi-region if you're
just bringing your workload to the to
our cloud and you're saying hey I wanted
to perform well and I want it to be cost
effective and I'm not sure what to do
Regional is a great choice for you
you're going to get the best performance
out of Google Cloud Storage if you put
it in Regional bucket and you will get a
very good cost
but we know a lot of you have additional
requirements aside from just running the
workload you have data protection
requirements you need the data to be in
two two regions not just one and you
also need to be able to run workloads in
multiple places you don't want to be
tied up if you're through the region it
could be because of Providence reasons
or perhaps you have you you have a
certain compute shapes you're looking to
use
and dual region buckets you set up you
can pick two regions yourself or you can
pick two regions that are automatically
uh paired together already and uh we
will automatically replicate the data
across those two regions it'll give you
an active active failover capability so
if a region goes down and you're you can
still read from that endpoint and the
data will be retrieved from the region
that's still running
this is a perform this is a performant
uh buckets they're they're on the same
level of performance as a regional
bucket and
um
it it uh it allows you to run your data
like I said seamlessly in in two
locations now a lot of you are saying
like two regions are great why not more
well
um oh I'm sorry well I also should
mention we um we added a couple features
to help you run uh dual region buckets
and that is uh replication monitoring
and uh the popularity has been growing
so we've also added the capabilities to
run it in Canada and Australia all right
so now those of you that want to uh love
this capability but you'd like to have
more regions what we offer is a
multi-region bucket so the multi-region
bucket essentially covers an entire
continent you can see all the dark blue
there covers most of Europe right we
also offer multi-region in the U.S and
Asia and what this allows you to do is
you can run your workload anywhere in
the Blue Area essentially across Europe
as shown and then it'll it'll pull the
data from that bucket and multi-region
buckets will store your data all across
that region in two locations so you have
copies of the data and you'll be fully
protected you'll have active active
failover experience the same as dual
region now because we you're allowing us
the ability to place this data where we
find it to be most cost effective we're
sharing that cost reduction with you and
so this is a more cost effective way to
achieve data protection and through Geo
redundancy
all right now this has been a really
popular storage location type and people
are trying to use it for all kinds of
things and one of those things is data
intensive workloads and we thought well
why don't we make it even better and add
a cache right so what we're announcing
today is uh I think we're called
anywhere cash the anywhere cache allows
you to put a cache in the same Zone as
your compute instance and you can see on
the screen I've got two caches and zones
A and B no cash in zone C you can put a
cache in all three zones or one zone or
any combination of zones you want you
don't pay to enable the cash you only
pay for what you use and you scale to
what you need so the cash is a Zone
local cash so it's fast it's simple you
enable it on the bucket and then as you
read data it automatically gets ingested
into the cache and the subsequent reads
all get served from cash it's a fully
consistent cache so if the data changes
underneath the system will will know and
and do the and serve a cache Miss and
retrieve the change data from the bucket
repopulate the cache you'll always get
consistent data
um it's also great when you combine
anywhere cash with the multi-region
buckets as if you recall the the
map that I showed you of Europe with
that a multi-region bucket with anywhere
cash would allow you to pick any Zone
throughout Europe or in the US if you
have a multi-region bucket in the U.S
and and run your workload there and have
it have a Zone local experience so what
I mean by that is like in the U.S you
have a multi-region bucket any Zone in
the U.S you can place the cash in
the cash will be as you read it will be
ingested into that cash in the same Zone
as your VM
and then all subsequent reads will come
from that zone local cache instead of
doing across Metro reads
um and so you'll have the local
experience
all right
um and we have other things to help you
with your data uh intensive workloads
one of the common patterns we see is
people with object storage create
folders by uh putting prefixes in front
of the defined prefixes in front of the
objects these Define prefixes then
are what the folder is and what we do is
in with this manage folders uh product
that we have just released is allow you
to create IAM policies based on these
prefixes so essentially you have the
ability to set I aim policy IAM policies
on each folder
right
um a few other things I'd like to show
you new products we've got four other
products I'd like to mention we have a
bunch more Beyond this but I think four
products that would be worthwhile
mentioning here for this crowd for data
intensive workloads the first one is a
lot of people are running hdfs workloads
on-prem we would like to help you get
those into the cloud so we have a
transfer service to move those hdf
workloads to the cloud for you in a
simple easy way
the next one is a cloud storage fuse
product for machine learning this allows
you to have a client a local
file client uh giving you file system
access to your GCS bucket
I'm fully supported by Google Cloud
the next one is performance related
those a lot of people care a lot a great
deal about performance when you're
running data intensive workloads grpc is
a great choice to uh to run accelerate
your workloads and it'll help save your
wall clock time and minimize the amount
of idle CPU time that you may have and
save you money
the last thing I want to mention is
custom audit information custom audio
information is a great way to help you
keep track of what's going on on and how
your data is being used it passes the
application and identity information for
service accounts so that you can track
them
and so these are the products that I
just want to make you all aware of and
let's give Sandeep a chance to talk
about and tell us about flipkart's
Journey
thanks Brad
so um just a quick brief about Flipkart
Flipkart is India's leading e-commerce
startup for last 16 years
and it is one of the most successful
startup stories in India
I'll uh talk about Flipkart scale to
give an idea of the complexity and the
size of things but in general
we have more than 450 million registered
users on platform which means the entire
population of United States and Canada
and then we still have 100 million more
left
to account for
and in terms of scale which I'll come to
slide later but to give an idea it is we
ingest more than 100 billion events on a
daily basis
so a couple of years back we decided and
we also run our own private data center
so for most of our history from day one
to 14 years we were running on our own
data centers and we have two off of Our
Own Private data centers
and the data platform that I'm going to
talk about today we were running it on
on-prem
then why is it that we decided to move
to gcp and that is what I'm going to
share my insights with you
so when we
step back and looked at what people were
doing and I had some of the smartest
people I believe on my team
we were doing a lot of work on managing
the infra because at this level of scale
there was a huge effort to manage the
infra and we were also managing scale
requirements which is like every we have
a yearly sale called the big billion Day
sales which our sales spikes 10x to 20x
during that sales period and that
becomes a technical challenge so a lot
of team members were busy on managing
either the infra or the skill issues and
I said like data platform team
that doesn't seems to be totally right
and my belief is that if we want to
change something whatever the team
members are doing or thinking today that
is what the state of the art will be six
months later in the company
so we decided to change and the things
that we wanted the developers and the
data platform thinking special to think
was not infra not scaling but things
about data platform data products and
also think about
optimization
so what kind of data products I wanted
team to think about see we do a
real-time funnel analytics at a scale of
100 billion of events ingested every day
during Peak seal sale period giving
real-time information to our leadership
we wanted to prepare data for our ML and
data science algorithms we want to spend
more effort in doing
data quality checks upfront so that it's
not the customer who's reporting data
issues and data quality issues but we
can run our own data unit test and data
Integrity test Etc
to remove almost a layer of analytics in
between the end user the business user
and the platform by using gen AI kind of
tools
the other thing is optimization so it is
great that uh
gcp can provide you with
unlimited storage and unlimited compute
and I think it puts us into a little bit
of confident situation
but I'll tell you it is not your and my
responsibility to test that out it is
very important that the data is
considered and compute and data are
optimized otherwise soon they become a
next another level of problem that is
unmanageable and we don't want to deal
with that
in the gcp what we found because they've
done the compute storage separation as
Brad was telling you and they support
both
um
the open source as well as their own
functional Services stack I think we
decided that we will be able to use
all of that
so here uh just a little detour the
number that we process on a daily basis
I think 130 billion messages I was
saying 100 million
during this transition we had to also
transfer 30 petabytes of data which is
hot data we also have more than 45
petabytes of cool data overall closer to
100 petabytes now
how big is 35 petabytes of data
I think if it transfer data in the best
case over a 10 gbps link 30 petabytes of
data takes a year to transfer if there
are no hiccups in the network
so having said that about the scale I
think the data optimization problem for
us was really important because we knew
from experience that if we take our eyes
away from the optimization
we will be soon dealing with problems of
scale that we don't have to deal with
and fortunately the gcp stack gave us
the flexibility
to either use pop sub or
for ingestion to use data proc bigquery
for compute site but we also could use
our own stack for which we are familiar
with which we have optimized over the
years of our own framework which was
built over the open source stack and I
think that helped us in
making sure that we are running the data
pipelines and other processes in the
most optimal fashion due to which we
could run
much more number of processes much more
richer algorithms over time
to give an idea of the stack that we are
using if you look carefully maybe this
is a complicated figure but basically
what it says is
that we we use Kafka to ingest from our
server side data to take care of the
back pressure and ingest it into Pub sub
from the millions hundreds of millions
of mobile devices the data is ingested
directly to Pub sub we do not have to
worry about scale and other issues and
then we also run Hadoop we run certain
of our workloads on hive which are
already suited or been optimized for
there we extensively run on bigquery
also and are able to sometimes recover
from errors or when we have to re-do the
computation due to human or certain
other errors related to data ingestion
we are able to do it quickly but overall
what this stack shows
is that we are able to mix the best of
thing coming from native gcp platform
offerings as well as open source
offerings and that's been one of the key
reason why we are also able to run in a
very optimized fashion
another interesting fact is that we did
complete this migration in under in
around six months of time
and this is a live migration where the
data pipelines are running 24 bar 7 hour
month and closure reports accounting
reports which have to be closed and
accounted for are getting closed every
month after month and in six months time
I think with a lot of support from
Google side both on
Tech stack and on the other aspect of
migration including optimization this
was pretty successful
and to close off this I think in post
migration I have seen from my personal
effect the speed of innovation
has really increased many folds uh
people are now developing data products
they're churning it out at much faster
rate the data quality related assertions
and able to cache data quality problems
much earlier as
uh been actually at a very good State
and could be famous last word I don't
know what's happening now
um and it's been a successful story
which has given us a breather to go and
innovate where it matters for the
company and not worry about scaling the
infrastructure or managing the
infrastructure
with this I'll hand over to Jason
I think you have just one more slide
here
cool
right
all right
give it up for Sandy
foreign
just wanted to say a thank you to Brad
for inviting me to share the stage with
them Google cloud is a strategic partner
of databricks and I feel honored to be
able to present to you guys today so
first of all who is databricks if you
haven't heard of us we are we are the
lake house company so we are the ones
who created and pioneered the concept of
the data lake house and what that is it
means you should be able to write your
data any type of data and one one time
in the place that's most scalable and
the cheapest place which would be GCS
and then leverage that one copy of your
data for all your different use cases
whether that be batch ETL streaming data
warehousing or artificial intelligence
and machine learning applications
we are the only um only only vendor
recognized by Gartner as a leader in
both the database Management Systems
quadrant as well as data science and
machine learning platform quadrant so
we're unique in that regard
and one thing to note is uh we were
co-founded by the original creators of
Apache spark so we've got open source
you know coursing through our veins and
and since our founding we actually
created a couple other open source
projects so one of them is mlflow which
allows you to have an open source
platform for how to do the complete
machine learning on lifecycle and as
well as Delta Lake which is what I want
to talk to you today Delta lake is the
de facto standard for how to manage
transactions on top of a data Lake
so what is Delta Lake
um it's a it's an open format what it
does is essentially whenever you're
writing data out to GCS what you're
going to do is with Delta Lake you're
going to be writing a whole bunch of
parquet files and alongside those
parquet files is a transaction log and
that transaction log is what allows you
to do inserts updates deletes merge
statements and do it concurrently across
multiple writers at the same time it
also gives you performance benefits
because now that you have this
transaction log you can treat that as a
manifest and so when you do go to do
queries you instead of doing a whole
bunch of different list calls to GCS now
you're just basically looking at the
Manifest and deciding what's the
smallest number of files and blocks that
I have to read to be able to satisfy a
query
we built Delta Lake from the ground up
to be able to do both batch and
streaming so when I was uh listening to
Sandeep talk I just uh I got um I felt
like oh we've got a lot of different
similarities here because we deal with
scale on a daily basis so we're
ingesting two exabytes of data every day
in Delta Lake and some of our customers
are ingesting up to five petabytes a day
on Delta Lake and because you have to
deal with data volumes that large you
can't just rely on batch processing
because you could get in a scenario
where if you're if your batch process
fails and you're you're
um your window is not big enough you
might not ever be able to catch up so
you have to be able to process data in a
streaming way and so we designed Delta
Lake from beginning to do both batch and
streaming
um we have the transaction like I talked
about offer some other benefits too so
we have something called change dataflow
that's built in and that means instead
of querying the table directly in the
static form you can query the actual
transactions in the transaction log and
get a stream of those transactions
likewise if you want to query a table as
it existed at a point in time in the
past you can take advantage of time
travel as well all thanks to the
transaction log
and so there's been a lot of different
benchmarking on different lake house
formats and all of them come out with
Delta Lake as being the fastest and if
you want to look at a really good one
there's one that Berkeley did I think
last year called the lake house
Benchmark lhb and it kind of like goes
to a number of different scenarios for
both querying as well as inserts and
merge statements and gives you a
holistic picture of of how all these
different formats operate and what how
they perform and what the read
amplification is and right amplification
is
so I'm really excited today to talk
about data bricks and how we integrate
so well with Google we've um we had a
really good partnership and when we
first deployed databricks we actually
leveraged gke to deploy the Clusters so
the way the databricks works is your
data stays within your cloud account
your Google account within your buckets
and then whenever you spin up clusters
to process that data those clusters stay
within your Google account as well and
so databricks is basically has a control
plane that's orchestrating all this on
your behalf but you're in complete
control
and we've been you know I mentioned that
databricks you know is a big believer in
open source technology and I Know It
aligns really well with Google's values
as well
um and the nice thing is once you write
all of your data once into Delta Lake on
GCS then you can bring whatever engine
you want to it so you can bring a
bigquery if you want to query that data
or a data proc if you want to do some
ETL processing databricks we have our
own engine we built a native vectorized
engine called Photon and it implements
the spark API so anything you can run on
Apache spark you can also run on our
Photon engine and and generally it runs
about seven to eight times faster so you
can take advantage of those performance
benefits on databricks as well
and the nice thing is that we're
available in the Google Cloud
Marketplace so you've already got data
bricks all you got to do is just go to
the Marketplace search for it find it
you get a 14 day free trial try it out
see what you like and because it's in
the marketplace it actually burns down
your Enterprise agreement as well so
um there's no reason not to try it
and one last thing before we get to uh q
a here is we announced something called
uniform earlier this year at our own
Summit and what uniform is is it's part
of the open source deltalay project and
there's a couple different lake house
formats out there so there's Delta Lake
which is part of the Linux foundation
and then there's Apache Iceberg and
Apache hoodie uh now some customers we
found are using two if not all three of
these and what they really want is they
want compatibility and portability so
what we've done is we've created
something called uniform where when you
write the data out to Delta Lake it'll
automatically replicate the metadata
that transaction log into the other
formats so for hoodie and Iceberg this
allows you to get all the performance
benefits of writing out to Delta Lake
and then if you need the portability of
being able to read that same data in
different engines then you can read it
as an iceberg table or the hoodie table
this is you know really useful because
some engines they end up implementing
one of these formats before the other
ones and so and then the customers are
caught just waiting forever all these
engines to catch up now you don't have
to wait anymore you can just use uniform
and write your data once and leverage it
across any engine so with that I think
I'm gonna invite up a
um Vivek and the others
[Music]